listen to this uh biden got covered
again and had the best week of his
presidency
really
i don't know
i don't know if this is related but
today kamala harris was seen rubbing
herself with a coughing monkey
well they just no not funny
they just declared monkey pox
really now we have to do monkey butts in
national emergency and listen this in
new york city they found one case of
polio but the health guy says well this
is just the tip of the iceberg and we
found it in the wastewater you know what
i've had it with viruses i really have
polio in the wastewater in new york
first okay
first i couldn't have unprotected gay
sex
then i couldn't eat at a chinese wet
market
and now i can't play in wastewater well
[ __ ] this
but
but no honestly biden had his best week
in a very long time jobs way up i mean
like crazy up we've gotten all the jobs
back from the pandemic unemployment is
3.5
gas prices way down and he got
and he got his big climate bill today
kristen kirsten cinema from arizona
you're familiar with
with her she's a
okay all right well she joined up
it's good
it's good to see the uh
good to see the democrats can be
bipartisan with themselves
but
she
this was me she was holding this up for
something called the
carried interest loophole
this is what very important to her and
they gave it up it's it's it's you know
something only hedge fund managers care
about do you care about this but she
she looked around scottsdale and said
it's about time someone stood up for the
wealthy
this is again
it's a tax loophole
that only involves hedge fund managers i
you know i've seen many campaign ads in
my life uh it's just firemen
farmers
you know welders
a kid pulling a dog in a wagon it's
rarely
hedge fund managers i've never seen one
with a guy it's morning in america and
i've been up all night snorting blow off
a hooker's ass i've never seen that
and not
me
[Laughter]
thank you mom um
but you know this is the big climate
bill not one republican voted for it
it's going to be 50 plus the vice
president passing this thing not what
you know they just environment they're
just not into it
there was just some way to get the earth
pregnant
oh that's uh
that
is the big story this week
kansas had an election
kansas
kansas had an election and abortion
rights was on the ballot and it won big
in kansas you know who spent a lot of
money on this trying to get it go the
other way against the catholic church
spent millions
millions that have could have gone on to
pay off kids they raped it's just a
shame
you